so I found out what the wet bulb
temperature means basically it's like a
if a thermometer that's covered in a
cloth that's soaked in water and it also
means that what do you what are you guys
are looking at now nothing again yeah
yeah
and also it's like the temperature after
like 35 degrees at like a certain
humidity your body can't
um sweat enough to cool you down so it's
dangerous and you can just die from like
what heat stroke is on uh whatever you I
don't know dehydration yeah I guess I
don't know damn yeah I definitely feel
Japan is like in that stage all month
basically it's just [__] hot it's
hell on Earth yeah it's like five
minutes outside and I'm like soaked yeah
I'm like I feel gross I I can't do
anything and I just stink I know
it's just you normally
I stink I swear the other day I covered
my entire body in antiperspirant yeah
the it stood no chance against Japanese
some my body was like nope the sweat is
coming out we cannot stop I remember
when you went for that phase we're like
I'm not using shampoo
and uh I still don't use much shampoo
your hair was like really ragged and
like [__] off just like rope
it's like carpet I still shouldn't be
like once a week
[Music]
[Laughter]
can you explain what's happening in this
picture
we should do like once every few weeks
yeah and uh the price came to this
777 yam and the staff like you are the
chosen one
you should post that to uh are mildly
interesting
I'll slash when did I ask
[Laughter]
back in the UK for Christmas
um and whatnot and celebrating the chess
boxing Charlie and I went through a
holiday in the UK yeah and the UK is
actually nice for a holiday sometimes
um but you you don't you don't get that
if you live in the UK you don't right
view the UK through the prism of like us
is a nice country so it's kind of like
nice to go back now and then below it's
good and uh we went to the Lake District
which we went to years before it's kind
of like a special place in the UK and we
went there and it was [__] [__]
because for five days it rained stormed
couldn't literally go out for five days
straight Jesus out of the UK yeah it was
the UK and uh yeah and I was like [__] I
bought the engagement ring I was gonna
do it here it's gonna be this magical
moment yeah and instead we're just stuck
in this like little person's house just
going oh the weather's crap so it's kind
of Tainted in my image but anyway I I I
wanted to
kind of Charlotte was like I think the
conversation came up about marriage as I
was kind of like yeah this will be fun I
was like yeah I think like we went to
dinner and I was like I'll lead her
astray I was like yeah marriage well
they're rubbish hey
Swig of my Merlot
and she's bring me another shoes boy
what do you mean I was like that's just
rubbish
if you ever hear me have a conversation
with Charlotte restaurant this is the
quality the level of quality you can
expect
[Music]
this is your genius idea yeah
we'll see but I bought the ring a few a
few weeks beforehand down in the UK
shows the ring got the shop and that day
actually when I was getting the Ring
Charlotte was traveling around the town
with her friend and I had to like keep
an eye out while I was in the shop yeah
walk past the window and see me getting
it but anyway I got the ring and um yes
I was like a marriage is rubbish if you
think about it who would want to do that
nonsense and she was like what do you
mean you don't want to you want to get
my idols on I won't think about it you
know like just like trying to lead her
Australia and we you know they didn't
finish she went back to our room chat
and she got really upset so wouldn't you
wouldn't marry me I was like wow
she's like you don't like like marriage
you know I thought we talked about it
before I was like oh
she's like upset crying a little bit I'm
like
laughing like a monster
she's like what do you mean you don't
want it and I'm just like
because I'm like the bag's over there
with the ring in it yeah and I'm like oh
if only she knew but I could I can just
be like well guess what good some
wedding ring well here's what I made
earlier yeah you can't get engaged even
like in a funny way yeah a memory of the
engagement would just be like trauma to
crying and control me like what do you
mean you bought it like it would just be
[__] so I had to like hold off but it
was really uncomfortable and like so we
had like four days of like just off off
the back of that maybe like yeah I'm
sure we'll get married soon don't worry
about it anyway I'll engage yeah and
then luckily oh yeah we got down to um
Turtle door it's like this rock yeah
yeah good they filmed Tears for Fears
music video there that's why I like it
and then I did it there and she I think
I I put the camera on the um because you
I I do think the engagement thing is
important some people literally just do
it on a sofa like marriage in it and
they're like yeah all right
some people really go like really far
yeah and like doing a [__] hot air
balloon yeah yeah yeah Egypt or
something
I just I'm one in the Middle Ground
Jackie Chan around more than 80 days
what the [__] is this dude what did you
do it oh I'll let you finish mine yeah
but like I I am so I wanted the middle
ground I wanted someone that was a nice
location yeah that was nice and so we've
I found durdle door the wind was like
[__] hurricane that day yeah
I put the camera down in the um it's in
the rocks
and I was like let's take a selfie she's
like oh yeah okay you took us out and I
was like all right I've got self timer
five seconds three two one I got Darwin
three two one will you marry me which
was like really I was like yes had it
the whole time and I think she was happy
but it made up for the awful [__] of
making her cry in the Lake District and
it was a nice happy ending it was a
lovely backdrop to it it's a nice memory
now yeah hell yeah about a bit well
um
like it was literally that bad and I'm
an idiot oh it's it's good to know that
I'm not the only one so I think they
always go wrong yeah yeah I'm not the
only one that [__] up his proposal and
it still went right
um so yeah like my idea
for you know the engagement was going to
be like a repeat of our very first date
as we ever did you know so you know like
like romantic yeah like like you how you
were saying some people go super extra I
wanted I'm more like a Sentimental
personal kind of person hot air balloon
no hot air balloons no special no
special things so on our first day we
cycled about we cycled down south Bank
along the Thames and there was this like
picturesque place that we stopped at and
we took one of our first pictures we'd
ever taken on like that first date uh
and I was like this has sentimental
value for me this place is sentiment to
Value so my idea for the engagement was
gonna be we're gonna repeat our first
dates and we're gonna stop at that point
and that's gonna be where I do it uh
obviously yeah this one we've been doing
for like seven eight years uh so it's
been a long time since I've been back to
London uh so I was like we were back
just for I guess like a month or
something so I was like honey let's uh
let's let's let's try let's do how do
you feel about repeating our first stay
you know that's that's nice right uh and
honestly the date went really well like
the beginning of the day we cycled down
stopped out all of the places we'd taken
like pictures before and you know it was
all going super well I thought that yes
this is the vibe I was like hoping for
and then we start getting closer to
where this where the engagement point
was meant to be and we start cycling
closer and closer and I start looking
around start seeing uh scaffolding
slowly get of course more and more down
in the UK
and I'm like huh that's weird that
wasn't there before
so I started like single single single
sweat drop starts like coming down and
I'm like sure sure it's just the area
choices sure it's always just the error
no there's nothing to worry about and
then we progressively the date goes on
and as we cycle closer the construction
and the scaffolding progressively get
more and more dense to the point where
that like so this this photogenic area
spot was just kind of like in an area
right next to the Thames like very
picturesque and we got to the entrance
of that area and it was just shut it was
just completely shut all closed off
thanks to construction and at this point
I'm like normally
when I have a plan I have like a plan B
so I'm like go on engineer you can
engineer a plan B and I like cycle
through
I I cycle through what my plan B is and
I'm like I don't have a plan B but what
do I do so uh like in a state of panic
I'm like
maybe there's another entrance somewhere
uh and uh Sydney uh Sydney's like yeah
sure let's let's go let's try going uh
find uh another entrance so we cycle
around and this entire area is just
closed off thanks to construction thanks
a lot city of London uh thanks thank you
thank you thank you so much yeah Big Ben
is still no it's good now that's good
it's good now like how many [__]
years half a decade yeah yeah so we we
cycle around the entire area looking for
an entrance but this this single area is
just closed off for construction so at
this point I just like in my mind I just
like given up I just like all right it's
done
this was a good plan maybe I'll try and
find another day and I turn over to
Sydney and you know Sydney knows me very
very well I think she could see how much
I was panicking and I think at this
point she could she could suss what was
going yeah she could suss what was going
on so I look over at Sydney about to say
let's just call it a day for the day and
I look at her and I take a breath and I
and she gives me she she gives me the
most evil eyes I've ever seen Sydney
give me in her life because I think she
knows what I was about to do and she's
like she's bailed she's like no you are
not bailing we are doing this today
and so I go I'm sorry look turn over and
go
do you want to keep cycling
I'm sorry I was just like maybe God will
smile down on me and maybe there's a
like a nice spot that's not like all
[__] painting and construction so
it's like good boy
she's like good boy uh so yeah we cycled
down for another like 20 minutes and
thankfully thankfully there's like a
place that looks like halfway decent
yeah and you know I set up the camera uh
for for the selfie as uh as you yourself
get the selfie took the video the
Twitter engagement yeah and you know sit
and threads yeah Sydney told me
afterwards that of course she knew what
was coming halfway through the day she
could see how much I was panicking but
when the ring came out she just
completely blanked and uh so did I
actually uh because we didn't realize
until after we saw the video
uh that I I didn't realize this because
I like I was just like so shot up with
adrenaline pulled out the ring she was
just like gas for air in shock uh even
though she knew I was coming uh she
didn't even say yes
did she
we
didn't what did she do she was just like
all right she gospel air she started
crying and I just hugged her and I just
I guess in the moment I I heard yes
please say that was a yes I beg of you
we didn't realize until after we saw the
footage that [__] you didn't actually
say yes in the moment I just hugged you
and assumed you did say yes oh my God
you pull away she's like no
she's like
it's like what was too late
I never said yes yeah it's one of those
things that you do Panic it's quite a
scary thing you wanted to go right and
yeah you know what I I thought she'd say
yes despite making her cry yeah there
was a lot of I was really nervous when I
did it right I think everyone is right
when they go through that yeah so I
guess so I don't know I can't really
imagine a dude just being like all calm
and collected being like Yep this is
going absolutely according to playing
I'm gonna [__] nail The Landing
everything's gonna go well that might
say beforehand
air balloon over Egypt yeah well I mean
I haven't so I mean I'm glad in a way
that it went wrong because it's just
become such a cool memory for me now
um I think you'd forget it otherwise
like oh [__]
oh yeah I have a wife now yeah I I just
think the memory regardless yeah it's a
core memory but the emotional the
emotional journey I took to get to that
final moment just like Amplified it just
yeah yeah I went through like so many
emotions in those like six hours or
however long that day is otherwise if
you if you if it went smoothly it'd be
like it's like when you beat a video
game on a too easy difficulty I should
have should have experienced it in a
harder mode you should have had like a
boy trip in front of us in the picture
or something yeah yeah
[Music]
you're gonna like artificial
artificially add like difficulty to your
engagement yeah I'll have like a higher
like a bunch of actors
there's got to be some kind of test you
know you can't just uh be married if you
really love me you'll know which one
it's easy to say yes you've got to prove
it you've ripped off Scott Pilgrim yeah
boss fights Boss music at least
I'm kidding I know that you are kidding
that's the worrying thing no no no you
must win my love if you want this ring
you must take it
dark souls
only then if you solve The Riddles all
right I hit it as a geocache you have to
go find it you you open up the box it's
just an empty box it's just like the
ring is shitty Mr B short it's like go
to the Bermuda Triangle and in there you
will see what you seek and it's like
it's the dead man
shake his hand it's got the ring on it
yeah
well congratulations yeah
congratulations lots of congratulations
for you yeah
book chess boxing [__] proposal what
else you got oh now that you uh have
moved yeah no it's good though nice how
doesn't ask you feel about it he never
wanted me to move to Chennai oh really
easy for him to get to take care by
playing when I said uh oh I'm thinking
of Sendai Tokyo who's like Sendai very
[__]
all right